-You've been doing this
for a while.
You've been covering
Washington for a while.
A lot of people say this is
the most unprecedented time
we're living in.
The last couple of days --
voting on a health-care bill
that nobody knows what's in it.
Is this as unprecedented
as we've been led to believe?
-It's wild. It's crazy.
I mean, nobody knows
what they're voting on.
They don't know how much
it's going to cost,
how many people are going to
get knocked off of health care,
who's gonna get it,
who isn't gonna get it.
They don't have a score
from the budget office, the CBO,
which is nonpartisan.
And so they're just
going through these bills
trying to get something
to say, "We didn't fail."
-And, you know,
while this is happening
and this is something that's
gonna affect so many people
and so many people's
health insurance,
which is a big deal --
And then you have something
like this morning
where all of a sudden, you know,
he starts tweeting
about how transgender
people are not gonna be
allowed in the military.
I have heard that the Pentagon
was completely
taken by surprise by this.
Is that what your reporting
has led to?
-Yeah.
I mean, it's a little scary
that the Pentagon, you know,
U.S. Intelligence
did not know that the president
was gonna change
the policy for transpeople.
And I don't think that
the Defense Secretary knew.
He is away on vacation
for a couple of days.
We've got a lot
of big military issues.
-Do you think he spoke
to the generals?
I know he was saying that.
Is that something that we can be
led to believe is true?
-Don't know. Can't say.
-Yeah.
-But the fact is
that the generals
have other big things --
Afghanistan, Syria,
you know, how to deal
with North Korea,
whether missiles
are going to go up
as early as tonight or tomorrow.
-As early as tonight?
-Yeah, maybe.
-Oh, I hope they wait
until after this airs.
I'd love to get one more in.
-One more in.
-And then, I mean, there's a lot
of theories floating around.
Do you think
that this is something,
an issue that is near and dear
to his heart
or that he's playing to his base
or that he's using it
to distract from
the health-care issue
that people talk about less
when he does a tweet
about transgender soldiers?
-It's hard to say
what's going on in his mind,
you know, what he's thinking.
I'm -- Seriously,
I can't interpret it,
but it certainly
has been a distraction
from the failure on health care.
It does play to the base.
It's a social issue,
and it contradicts completely
what he said
during the campaign.
So it's hard to figure out that
this is near and dear to him
if it's not something
he was talking about
when he was running for office.
-One of the things,
covering foreign policy,
you have to cover the Secretary
of State, Rex Tillerson.
He has not been taking
a lot of questions.
Would you say this is the least?
-Uh, yes. [ Laughs ]
-In your time, there's never
been a Secretary of State
that's allowed less access?
-Absolutely.
-And you've tried very hard,
very noble efforts.
Here you are asking him
some questions
at the end of a photo op.
Let's take a look real quick.
-Thank you!
-Thank you, guys.
We're leaving.
-Thank you. Andrea. Andrea.
-The press is departing.
-We haven't had
any time in here.
-I'm so sorry.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm -- You know what?
-I mean, that is humiliating.
-That, yeah.
You looked like a woman
who was lost in a shopping mall
at the end.
Also, it's interesting
when people say "thank you,"
and you get the sense
they're not that thankful.
And, you know, the other thing
is he is not letting
the press fly with him.
And here is a guy
who is taking trips
to obviously
everywhere across the globe,
and so you have to --
The press has to fly commercial
to try to catch up with him.
Has that made your job
even harder?
-It's impossible because you
cannot fly from here to there,
from country to country,
without a military plane.
I don't have one.
-Yeah.
-And we pay our way on this,
so this is not a budget issue.
They say it's a budget issue.
But he doesn't want to have
the press corps around.
So he has one person with him --
one person from
the media now that --
He sort of represents all of us.
But the fact is that
for decades now
Secretaries of State
have briefed us on the plane
or had their top officials
briefing us.
He doesn't have
that many top officials
'cause they haven't
filled the vacancies,
which is another whole issue.
But it really is hurting
American diplomacy.
It's not good
for us as a country
to not have the press
able to say,
"Well, this is what the goal is
of this administration
or this secretary."
It also sends
a really bad signal, I think,
to regimes in China,
in Turkey, in Russia
where reporters don't only
not get press conferences.
They get locked up.
They get killed.
I mean, there has always
been a tradition
where the
U.S. Secretary of State,
Republicans and Democrats,
bring the press corps along.
And if they don't have
press conferences there,
they --- he or she
will hold a press conference
to show that we believe
in freedom of the press.
-That is very disturbing.
I mentioned you've been
doing this a long time,
and you are
sort of a trailblazer
as a female journalist.
And very early on, you noticed
a bit of the distinction
that people in charge
will make between female
and male reporters.
You covered Three Mile Island,
which was obviously
a big story.
And what was your beat
that you were in charge
of Three Mile Island?
-I covered -- I was
the NBC energy correspondent,
so I covered nuclear energy,
and this was
a potential meltdown.
So it was on my watch.
-And so what happened
when you tried
to go report from
Three Mile Island?
-Well, a very kindly,
paternalistic bureau chief,
a lovely man said, when
I noticed that five days in,
I was the only correspondent
not going in
and covering this thing --
I went and said,
"How come I'm the only one
who's not going
to Three Mile Island?"
And he said,
"Because you are a woman
of child-bearing age."
-Wow.
-And I said,
"Has it occurred to you
that men's balls
are as vulnerable
to radiation
as women's ovaries?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's great. It's very --
-I mean,
I got there the next day.
They sent me right out.
-You got there the next day.
Also, I want to say
that's very noble
because for all the doors
that weren't open to women
for so long,
the one that you would think
they'd be happy to have closed
is the door
to Three Mile Island.
But you --
I think that speaks a lot
to the integrity you have
as a journalist.
And please keep up
the good work, Andrea.
It's just lovely
having you here.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Andrea Mitchell everybody.
"Andrea Mitchell Reports" airs
weekdays at noon on MSNBC.